can you give an introduction
to psychedelics like a whirlwind
overview maybe what are psychedelics
and what are the kinds of psychedelics
out there and
in whatever way you find meaningful to
categorize yeah
you can categorize them by their
chemical structure
so phenethylamines tryptamines
ergolines um that is
is less of a meaningful way to classify
them i
i think that their pharmacological
activity their receptor activity is the
best way
well let me let me start even broader
than that because there i'm talking
about the classic psychedelics
so broadly speaking when we say
psychedelic
that refers to for most people a broad
number of compounds that work in
different pharmacological ways
so it includes the so-called classic
psychedelics
that includes psilocybin
and salosine which are in mushrooms lsd
dimethyltryptamine or dmt it's in
ayahuasca people can smoke it too
mescaline which is in peyote and san
pedro
cactus um and those all work by hitting
a certain subtype of serotonin receptor
the serotonin 2a receptor
it's they act as agonists at that
receptor
other compounds like pcp
ketamine mdma
ibogaine they all are more broadly
speaking
called psychedelics but they work by
very different ways pharmacologically
and they have
some different effects including some
subjective effects even though there's
enough of an overlap in the subjective
effects
that you know people informally refer to
them
as psychedelic and i think what that
overlap is you know compared to say
you know caffeine and cocaine and you
know ambien
etc um other psychoactive drugs is that
they have strong effects in altering
one's sense of reality and including the
sense of self
and i should throw in there that that
cannabis more historically like in the
70s has been called a minor
psychedelic and i think with that latter
definition it it it does fit that
definition particularly if one doesn't
have a tolerance so
you mentioned serotonin so most of the
effect comes from something around like
the the chemistry
around neurotransmitters and so on so
it's uh
chemical interactions in in the brain or
is there other kinds of interactions
that have this kind of
perception and self-awareness altering
effects well as far as we know all of
the
the psychedelics of all the different
classes um
we've we've talked about
their major activity is caused by
receptor level
events so either acting at the post
receptor
side of the synapse in other words
neurotransmission operates by
you know one neuron releasing
neurotransmitter into a synapse a gap
between the two neurons and then the
other
neuron um receives they have it has
receptors that receives and then there
can be an
activation um you know caused by that so
it's like a pitcher and a catcher
so all of the major psychedelics work by
either acting as a pitcher mimicking a a
a
a a pitcher or a catcher so for example
the classic psychedelics
they fit into the same catcher's mitt on
the post receptor
post-synaptic receptor side as serotonin
itself
but they do a slightly different thing
to the to the cell to the neuron
than serotonin does um there's a
different signaling pathway after that
initial activation
something like mdma works at the
presynaptic side
the pitcher side and basically it floods
the synapse or the gap between the cells
with a bunch of serotonin the natural
neurotransmitter so it's like the the
pitcher in a baseball game all of a
sudden just starts throwing balls like
every every second everything we're
talking about is it
uh often more natural meaning
found in the natural world you mentioned
cacti
cactus or is it uh chemically
manufactured like
artificially in the lab so the classic
psychedelics there's
um what are the classics so yeah
using terminology that's not chemical
terminology not like the terminology you
see in titles of papers
academic papers but more sort of common
parlance
right it would be good to kind of define
their you know their effects like how
they're different
and so it includes lsd psilocybin which
is in mushrooms
mescaline dmt which one is muscle
mescaline is in
the different cacti so the one most
people will know
is is peyote but it also shows up in san
pedro or peruvian torch
and all of these classic psychedelics
they have at the right dose you know and
typically
they have ex very strong effects on one
sense of reality and
one sense of self what some of the
things that makes them different than
other more broadly speaking psychedelics
like mdma
and and others is that they're um
at least the major examples there are
some exotic ones that differ
but the ones i've talked about are
extremely safe at the physiological
level
like there's like lsd and psilocybin
there's no known lethal overdose
unless you have like really severe you
know
heart disease you know because it
modestly raises your blood pressure so
the same person might be hurt shoveling
snow or going up the stairs
you know that could you know have a car
they could have have a cardiac event
because they've taken a um uh one of
these drugs but for most people
you know someone could take a thousand
times what the effective dose is and
it's not going to cause any organ damage
affect the brain stem make them stop
breathing so in that sense
you know it's they're freakishly safe at
the physiolog i would never call any
compound safe because there's always a
risk they're freakishly safe at the
physiological level i mean you can
hardly find anything over the counter
like that i mean aspirin's not like that
caffeine is not like that most drugs
you take five ten twenty
maybe takes 100 but you get to some
times the affected dose and it's going
to kill you
yeah or cause some serious damage and so
that's that's something that's
remarkable
about these most of these classic
psychedelics that's incredible by the
way that you can
go on a hell of a journey in the mind
like probably transformative potentially
in a like deeply transformative way and
yet
there's no dose that most people would
have a
lethal effect that's kind of fascinating
there's this duality between the mind
and the body
it's like uh it's the okay sorry if i
bring him up way too much but david
goggins it's like uh
you know the kind of things you go on on
the long run
like the hell you might go through in
your mind your mind can take a lot and
you can go through a lot with the mind
and the body will just be its own thing
you can go through hell
but uh after a good night's sleep be
back to normal
and the body is always there so bringing
it back to goggins it's like you can do
that without even destroying your knee
or whatever
coming close and riding that line that's
true so the unfortunate thing about the
running which he uses running to test
the mind
so the the aspect of running
that is negative in order to test the
mind you really have to
uh push the body like take the body
through a journey
i wish there was another way of uh doing
that in the physical exercise space
i think there are exercises that are
easier on the body than others
but running sure is a hell of an
effective way to do it
and one of the ways that where it
differs is that
you're unlike exercise you're
essentially
you know most exercise required to
really get to those intense levels
you really need to be persistent about
it right i mean it'll be intense if
you're really out of shape just
you know jogging for five minutes but to
really get to those intense levels you
need to you know have the dedication and
so
some of the other ways of of altering um
subjective uh effects or states of
consciousness take that type of
dedication psychedelics though i mean
someone takes the right dose
they're strapped into the roller coaster
um and
some something interesting is going to
happen and i really like what you said
about that
that that that distinction between the
mind or the contrast between them
the mind effects and the the bodily
the body effects because um
i think of this i i i do research with
all the drugs you know caffeine alcohol
methamphetamine
cocaine alcohol legal illegal
most of these drugs um
thinking about say cocaine and
methamphetamine
you can't give a to a regular user you
can't safely give
a dose where the regular cocaine user is
going to say
oh man that's like
that's the strongest coke i've ever had
you know um
because you know you get it past the
ethics committee and you need approval
and i wouldn't want to give someone
something that's dangerous so to go to
those levels
where they would say that you would have
to give something that's physiologically
riskier yeah you know psilocybin
or lsd you can give a dose at the
physiological level that is like
a very good chance it's going to be the
most intense
psychological experience of that
person's life yeah and have zero
chance for most people if you screen
them of killing them
the big risk is behavioral toxicity
which is a fancy way of saying doing
something stupid
i mean you're really intoxicated like if
you wander into traffic or you fall from
a height
just like plenty of people do on high
doses of alcohol
and the other kind of unique thing about
about psych
classic psychedelics is that they're not
addictive which is
pretty much unheard of when it comes to
so-called drugs of abuse or drugs that
people
at least at some frequency
choose to take you know most of what we
think of as drugs
you know even caffeine alcohol cocaine
cannabis
most of these you can get into alcohol
you can get into a daily use
pattern and that's just extreme
so unheard of with psychedelics most
people have taken
these things on a daily basis it's more
like
they're building up the courage to do it
and then they build up a tolerance or
yeah
they're in college and they do it on a
dare can you take take acid seven days
in a row
yeah that type of thing rather than a
self-control issue yes
where you have and say oh god i gotta
stop taking this i gotta stop drinking
every night i gotta
cut down on the coke whatever so that's
the classic psychedelics uh
what are the uh what's a good term
modern psychedelics or
more maybe psychedelics that are created
in the lab what else is there
right so mdma is the big one and i
should say that that with the classic
psychedelics that lsd is sort of
you can call it a semi-synthetic because
there's there's there's
natural from from both ergot and in
certain seeds
um morning glory seeds is one example
there's a very close
there are some very close uh chemical
relatives of lsd so
lsd is close to what occurs in nature
but not quite it's
but then when we get into the the other
um
non-classic psychedelics probably the
most prominent one is mdma
people call it ecstasy people call it
mali um
and it is uh it differs from
classic psychedelics in a number of ways
it can be addictive but not so it's like
you can have cocaine on this end of the
continuum
and classic psychedelics here continuum
of addiction continuum of addiction you
know so it's certainly no cocaine
it's pretty rare for people to get into
daily use patterns but it's possible
and they can get into more like you know
using once a week pattern
where they can find it hard to to stop
but it's
it's somewhere in between mostly towards
the to the
classic psychedelic side in terms of
like relatively little addiction
potential um
but it's also more physiologically
dangerous i think that the
certainly the therapeutic use um it's
showing really promising effects for
treating ptsd and the models that are
used i think those are
extremely acceptable when it comes to
the risk benefit ratio that
you see all throughout medicine um but
nonetheless that we do know that at a
certain
dose and a certain frequency that mdma
can cause long-term
damage to the serotonin system in the
brain so it doesn't have that level of
kind of freakish bodily safety that
that the classic psychedelics do and it
has more of a heart load
a cardiovascular i don't mean kind of
emotion i mean
in this sense although it is very
emotional and that's something unique
about its uh
subjective effects but it's more of a
oppressor and uh the terminology used in
sort of uh
like a freakish capacities allowing you
from a researcher perspective but a
personal perspective too of taking
a journey with uh say some of these
psychedelics
that is um the heroic dose as they say
so like
these are tools that allow you to take a
serious mental journey whatever that is
that's what you mean and with mdma
there's a little bit
it starts entering this territory where
you got to be careful about the risks
uh to the body potentially so yes that
in the sense that you can't kind of push
the dose up as high
as you safely as one can if they're in
the right setting like in our research
as they can with the with the classic
psychedelics but probably more
importantly
the just the nature of the effects with
mdma aren't the full
on psychedelic it's not the full journey
you know so it's sort of a psychedelic
with rose-colored glasses on
um a psychedelic that's more of it's
been called more of a heart trip than a
head trip
the nature of reality doesn't unravel
as as frequently as it does with classic
psychedelics
but you're able to more directly sense
your environment so your perception
system still works it's not completely
detached
from reality with mdma that that's true
relatively speaking that said at most
doses and of classic psychedelics you
still have a tether
to reality changes a little bit when
you're talking about smoking dmt or
smoking five methoxy dmt
um which are some interes interesting
examples we could talk more about but
with um yet with mdma
it it's for example it's it's very rare
to have a
uh what's called an ego loss experience
or a sense of transcendental
unity where one really
seemingly loses the psychological
construct of the self
you know but um mdma it's very common
for people to have this
you know they still are perceiving
themselves as a self but
uh it's common for them to have this
this warmth
this empathy for humanity and for their
friends and loved ones
so it's more it's and you see those
effects under the classic psychedelics
but if that's a subset of what the
classic psychedelics do so i see mdma in
terms of its subjective effects
is if you think about um venn diagrams
it's sort of
mdma is all within the classic
psychedelics so okay
everything that you see on a particular
mdma session
sometimes a psilocybin session looks
just like that
but then sometimes it's completely
different with psilocybin it's a little
more
narrowed in terms of the variability
with mdma
you